hey guys what's up this is andrew for
10senses.com
so as usual guys i'm here to make some
technical analysis i'm here to show you
all the different tools and techniques
that i like to use
at work to set up my trades and to make
some money
so today i want to show you what we see
on gamestop
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so power stem frame as
usual
let's have a look at this chart and
let's see what we are having
so i did my last update around this
level i think we're trading around
180 so let me go actually to our little
frame let's make some shorter term
analysis
first and then we're going to take a
step back
so this was on the 10th of may so this
is the whole week we are having all
right the past 10 days
even that you can see the price action
going back from 130
to right now 176. this looks good to me
i did my last video
around here and i was telling you guys
that we expect some consolidation that
we
just finished the third wave of this
first wave here
and that we probably going to conceal
that little bit
and then go higher so for now this is
what is happening
we having this fourth wave that to me is
complete and
we just started the fifth wave so i
expect the fuse wave to go to the
200 level so next week so let's see
this would be a strong move up of yeah
thirty percent not that much for game
stuff and why
do i want to have this because guys if
if the price action needs to go higher
we always gonna start with nimples
impulsive
moves start with an impulse that's the
rule
and an impulse you can see the
difference between for example this wave
here
that is corrective you can see it's
going higher then much lower
it doesn't look like you know very clean
it is not like impulsive at all and
of course it gets rejected and it
corrects here we had this
impulse this abc was actually very
impulsive
but it was coming after a very bearish
period so this was as well corrective
here we having this whole correction
that lasts for the past two months
and we for now are having something that
finally
looks like an impulse because you can
see that here the price action
is steady it's just going higher it took
you know 37 in 10 days and
with the third wave that is impulsive
once again as i always
tell you guys here we are still missing
the volumes and gamestop you can see the
volumes are not picking up the mag
determined positive on a daily time
frame which is good
and we just miss the volume to actually
look
very very bullish for now what we need
to do guys we closed above the 173
level which is very good we are trading
above the moving averages
all of them on the first time frame so
this is bullish as well guys
i don't have any bearish sign everything
looks very good to me
i just want as i told you guys in my
previous video i want to take
back this level the trendline that is
connecting this high and this high
actually for amc chart guys we took it
so that's why amc had a very
strong week last week even stronger than
gamestop and where we saw the volumes
actually increasing
and for this to happen we need to break
this 193
level right now all right so let's call
it the 190 level
if gamestop trades above that and closes
above that
on the daily time frame this would look
very very good and we will probably uh
finish
this first wave then correct and then do
the
third wave that is going to be you know
the real move up
like we are having for amc if i am
correct
so that's it for me guys i expect like i
said
a move up uh quite strong next week i
want the 190 level to be taken back
so that this bullish case is confirmed
for me
so i hope you enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
going to be the first to know when i
upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys